une armée cyber oui ça on peut en parler
donnant les moyens pour lutter contre
ces cyber-attaques la guerre en les
crèmes fait planer une nouvelle menace
en occident celle de cyber attaques
russes aujourd'hui l'armée numérique
fait partie intégrante de l'arsenal des
pays développés autant sur le plan
offensif que défensif en france l'agencé
nationale de sécurité des systèmes
d'information inciter les entreprises et
les administrations à renforcer leurs
rangs deux jours après le début de la
guerre le ministère de l'intérieur a
exhorté tous les préfets à rester
vigilant face aux risques de cyber
attaques élevée qu'elle est réellement
l'ampleur de la menace la france
peut-elle y faire face on y répond dans
fac
en matière de cyberdéfense là aussi à
développer une véritable expertise ans
de même beaucoup plus tôt que 10 à la
fin de la guerre froide les stratèges
russes comprennent qu'il n'est plus
question de gagner une guerre
conventionnelle il cherche alors à
maintenir leur arsenal r moderniser
leurs forces et surtout à développer
leurs moyens de mener une guerre de
l'information plusieurs déclarations
très claires au début au milieu des
années 90 qui stipulent qu'ils allaient
monter des bataillon du régiment de
guerriers de la formation de cyber
guerriers et c'est comme ça qu'ils sont
construits en puissance qui a commencé à
s'exprimer au début des années 2000 joe
biden au début de sa mandature rencontre
vladimir poutine en leur exposant les
limites à ne pas franchir 5 et 9 cette
situation porte ses fruits des groupes
décidèrent hackers russes disparaissent
aussitôt mais le 23 février veille de
l'invasion rouge plusieurs
administration ukrainienne subissent une
cyber attaque d'ampleur
plusieurs sites celui du ministère de la
défense de l'intérieur et des affaires
étrangères
le site du parlement et de deux banques
commerciales sont attaqués il ya des
attaques de déni
quelques heures après la déclaration de
guerre de vladimir poutine le réseau
satellitaire diaz at elle sur une
connexion en ukraine et dans différents
pays d'europe et victime d'une
cyberattaque des milliers de personnes
sont privées d'une connexion internet
d'autres signes sont visibles depuis
plusieurs mois le satellite russe look
effectué d'inexplicable aux manoeuvres
venant se placer sous l'effet taux
d'émission de satellites occidentaux les
câbles sous marins constituent également
une cible potentielle il assure plus de
90 % des connexions internet
international l'europe en étant pour de
nombreux usages une mise en défaut de
ces câbles aurait des conséquences
économiques désastreuses mais si des
signes de menaces qu'on perd ses petits
il est difficile d'identifier clairement
les agresseurs potentiels et une cyber
guerre qui ne dit pas son nom parce
qu'en plus elle est faite de manière
mais c'est anonyme dans la mesure où
dans le cyberespace
attribuer une attaque n'est pas aussi
simple que ça dans le contexte d'une
scie derrière est d'autant plus facile
de se cacher et les rares que les
attaques soient des attaques d'états il
faut quand même savoir que une
éventuelle cyber attaque
déclenchée par un état très considéré
comme un acte de guerre par l'otan donc
c'est pas complètement innocent et
l'ansea aussi a bien mis en garde contre
le fait qu'on ne pouvait pas à l'heure
actuelle exactement compte tenu de la
nature même si vous d'aider les pirates
informatiques ou des hackers
être sûrs qu'ils souhaitent diligentée
par un état c'est fiable sont des
pirates non étatiques mener leur action
sans mettre en cause directement la
responsabilité gouvernementale
des russes utilisent des cybers
mercenaires des pseudos groupe des
groupes pseudo et ati on sait qu'ils
sont soutenus par l'état mais qui sur le
net s'identifient comme des groupes
autonomes et s'il est difficile
d'identifier clairement les agresseurs
il est compliqué aussi de cerner les
objectifs visés et les modes d'action
par exemple un virus peut être entre les
dents un réseau et se révéler mais aussi
bien plus tard la difficulté ça va être
notamment de bien détectée
qu'il n'y a pas de charge dormantes
c'est à dire que à l'occasion d'une
intrusion qui a peut-être se dérouler il
ya plusieurs semaines voire pourquoi pas
plusieurs mois qu'il n'y a pas de charge
active et face à ces menaces la france a
développé une stratégie de défense tous
les pays ont désigné les secteurs
stratégiques qui permettent la
continuité de la vie en société la
france a été un des premiers pays en
occident à mettre en place des mesures
de prévention cela a été initiée avec
une loi de programmation militaire au
milieu des années 2000 en france par
exemple la loi a désigné au sein de
douze secteurs d'activité alors c'est
les transports c'est l'énergie ces
traitements de l'eau services financiers
les télécommunications et au sein de ces
secteurs on a identifié des entreprises
dont la continuité de service est
strictement nécessaire à la collectivité
nationale
ces entreprises ont donc mis en place
des mesures de prévention et des
procédures de sécurité un peu plus de
300 entreprises dont la liste est
classifié qui augmente d'ailleurs
régulièrement qui sont ces entreprises
issues de cette douzaine de secteurs
d'activités de manière à leur demander
d'avoir des politiques très strictes de
protection de leurs systèmes
d'information l'union européenne à
renforcé cette protection en 2018 avec
un directive nice en terme de défense
l'anticipation est primordial elle
permet de détecter si reconstruire la
tacc et trouver des moyens alternatifs
la première faille reste l'homme toute
infection de grande ampleur a démarré
par un lien par un clic souvent à
volontaire et donc plus le les
utilisateurs que nous sommes quelles que
soient les grades les échelons
hiérarchiques les domaines d'activité au
sein des entreprises ou des ou des
administrations doivent être conscientes
que fils peut constituer ou elle peut
constituer un vecteur d'infection dans
le cyberespace les attaques visent
toujours les points les plus faibles
elle vise les bases des centres
d'intérêts vitaux dans lesquelles ils ne
peuvent conduire la meilleure réponse
reste alors la conscience de tresques et
l'appréhension métro désormais en france
le niveau de défense est suffisamment
élevé pour faire place à des
potentialités on est monté en puissance
dans d'excellentes conditions avec une
excellente organisation ça c'est un
point extrêmement positif est ce qui
fait qu on a pu bien rassembler les
forces on a une vraie compétence
technique et le cimer pour moment est
devenu pratiquement une armée en 2d
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]